bonjour à tous j'ai le grand plaisir de
vous inviter à la première édition des
piques démocrates cette année qui se
dérouleront les 23 24 25 juin prochain
et donc dans chacun de nos départements
nos responsables locaux vont essayer
d'organiser dans un lieu plutôt sympa un
endroit où on va se retrouver un peu sur
le modèle de la Fête des Voisins entre
nous mais bien au-delà de nous il faut
évidemment que c'est le week-end
démocrate soit ouvert très largement au
monde associatif au monde consulaire
record intermédiaire à toutes les
Françaises et à tous les Français qui
ont envie de s'engager politiquement
pour leur pays et pour la République
dans les temps que nous traversons je
crois plus que jamais il faut que nous
soyons républicains et démocratiques